[Music]
what is the biggest
age gap between uh and in terms of
couples
that you would be comfortable with 18
and 88
interesting places wait what five years
i don't have one because i just feel
like if you fight with someone you vibe
with somebody yeah that's it
well like right that's right because on
90 day beyonce right now there's this
indian guy that's like with his grandma
and he loves her to death and his
parents doesn't accept
but she's like old she's like 70. she's
older than his parents
than they love each other yeah yeah yeah
for me yeah as long as they're
as long as everyone's legal yeah true
that's a good point well
let's stay 18 that's still legal but
she's a baby
or he or he i know but there are other
people i'm like
you [ __ ] live your life as long as
you're legal i don't give a [ __ ] but for
myself right for ourselves ourselves
ourselves oldest i could do is like five
year and that's the cat
up or down up and then down it's like
none like zero years really you're not
dating
younger dude no yeah but what if you're
40. um
what does that mean and then you're like
and he's like and he's like 35 and
you're like
oh bro you're a [ __ ] baby
yeah some people i don't think i can get
past it cause some people also look now
i don't know but i
really don't think i'm 60 and you're
like i'm robbing the cradle
he is 50 years old 55
55 55. you know what's great is that
um i don't have to worry about it
because i'm right right we're right
because casey's forever and always
wait how what is the gap of the age here
less than two years one and a half
yeah and you're older i'm older yeah
okay be ironic if i was
a girl well here's the thing they'll be
so funny five years younger you're like
hey
so in theory my scenario is what if you
actually don't know their age until
you're already in love
like what if you're like you just never
get to that well if you're in love your
love
look at what i'm saying like like i'm
saying in your case it's like if you
meet someone
and you never knew their age for like a
while some reason like y'all never
talked about age yeah
i'm too nosy that's gonna come up so is
that something you asked immediately how
old are you no kidding
you count the rings oh you got you got
the rings under their eyes not a good
habit joe
i know that yeah men
should yes men should this is so good
let me ask you this uh dating down
dating up in age
would that be a different age gap for
you guys to consider nope
yeah i told you the age gap it depends
on anthony
it probably just depends on what you
want right like for example for me if
i'm gonna date older then
and i want kids then i like
[Music]
that's one way to put it so the salty
duck eggs salty duckies
and then like thousand-year-old eggs i'd
say i would say
my girlfriend right now is six and a
half years younger than me and i think
that that's probably damn cradle robber
that's fine
vice tim standards you're [ __ ]
robbing the cradle
i'm just kidding like i said i don't
judge other people
i think that's fine because honestly and
and it also depends on like
and back to like you know because i date
women and men like i feel like maybe
with men i would want them older
but then with women doesn't matter
because you're like i don't want an old
hag
i want to [ __ ] find old fox no i'm
talking about like fine oh
with women it does it matters doesn't
matter less
because it's like it's almost like a
height like height for example right
it's like you want a tall man but a
short woman no i don't
really know that's what i'm saying it
doesn't matter i don't know to be honest
i have to figure it out i have some
unpacking to do
oh dang i want to date someone who looks
exactly like yo
let's move it's hard i'm packing it
the u-haul is outside the u-haul's
outside yeah uh i feel like
i feel like within eight years
is is is fine we're not asking you the
right question 30 right now if i date a
guy
or a girl who's 22 or someone who's like
38
[ __ ] it i think eight is nice because i
would be 38 so we would date god
you'd be okay with that because they
could be stupid [ __ ] yeah you're just
like
hello yeah eight years is not bad then
bart isn't here okay there are no rules
is that cool
all right so according to experts uh
and societal norms there is a general
rule to go
by and and they say rule it's look more
like
a suggestion so they're not don't take
this as concrete information and
you're wrong if you don't follow this
but if you're gonna date
uh date down you what you want to do is
divide your age by two and then add
seven oh twenty two one what kind of
[ __ ]
hold up i need to kill another two
divide your age
by two and then add seven to calculate
the
socially acceptable minimum age of your
partner twenty-five wait
that you said you're 38 37 37 so
what's that difference i don't know
here's part number to divide
that's wait what what what's happening
12 years 25 oh the difference you're
talking yeah so slow
12 years oh so basically what it's
saying is as you get older
divided by 2 plus 7. so 39
if you're 65 then 39 and a half that's
why
it kind of makes sense right because if
you're an 80 year old you'd be like 47 i
guess is fine but we're talking about
socially acceptable not legal and i'm
already socially unacceptable
so [ __ ] it i said he's just on a
different scale of measurement
no all i'm saying is that i don't go by
what's socially acceptable
i go by what my heart accepts wait so
well you should though because just
legally yeah well
but that's what i meant is like they're
socially acceptable and there's legal
right socially acceptable is judgment
from other people but it
it's not it's legal is a judgment from
the law
like like let's say you're a 21 year old
dude and your
like girlfriend is 55 right that's not
socially acceptable but it's legal yeah
yeah gotcha well i mean is it not
socially acceptable because people not
really
society just sucks and they judge i
think you would just judge it
that's what i mean but it's socially
unacceptable well i don't know if i
would judge it i would be i would give
them one of these oh
but you're you're but you're uh
progressive you're yeah you are
you you're bi and all this stuff right
like that's a progressive
way of aggressive relationships i have
progressive insurance
but it's not it's not traditional and
it's not conservative so like your
your form of dating is not like the norm
because even like when we saw couples
like you know demi moore and ashton
kutcher like i didn't mind that
yeah i mean either whatever the world
did this is sarah paulson
and and uh damn it she's a lot older
yeah i forget her name oh my goodness
i know i think the world is not ageist
they are ugliest
like they're they're they're against
ugly so those couples are beautiful
right so if you talk about the age
difference
but if you look at like a hugh heff and
then a playboy colin taylor
weird right that name i'm sorry oh hold
on if you have a difference between
someone who's old and young but if
the old man or woman looks ugly then
they'll be like oh i'm against this
but if they were too beautiful i don't
even think it's an ugly thing it might
be like a youthfulness
you know like yeah that's what i mean oh
okay like they look young or they look
they don't look their age or like
whatever right they might have fit in
that
in the the thing i don't know what their
ages are oh that's true they might have
been technically it might have been
socially acceptable hugh hef on the
other hand
i don't think that's he's an anomaly
though no he's not he's just rich
he's on brand he's on brand the fact
that everybody knows who is already an
anomaly
right true very true wait i'm sorry what
does that anomaly mean again
it's like an aberration something that
sticks out one out of not the norm
it's not normal right but if you were to
just see like a hugh half
like character like a fat billionaire
let's not
let's not fat shame super super old
male 1 undesirable old billionaire and
super young girls right next to him like
18 year olds next to like a like an 80
year old dude
you know and he wasn't hugh hefner you'd
be like
right that's weird so basically if
you're famous you can get away with
anything
yes and good looking all right and good
luck and good looking
yes have no good looking to y'all he was
when he was younger yeah when he was
younger he was pretty good looking right
i guess everyone was yeah no it's all
downhill from here
no all right so on the flip side if
you're trying to
uh date up in age oh here's the math
equation for this oh there's more all
right
so to figure out your ceiling date you
would subtract seven from your
current age and then double that number
oh sixty
wait i can't okay thirty fifty forty six
wait
forty so subtract seven
and then double i don't think if i was
with a 58 year old would be cool or
46. yeah 40. wait that's not that old at
all 30.
yeah i'm 30. that's the same same 96 oh
yeah nice
so 22 and uh for 48
eight six so we're good at math here
i'm struggling right now i'm struggling
i'm [ __ ] with a 58 year old [ __ ] no
but it depends on how young they look
and how hot they are you just said [ __ ]
no joe
j lo is 50. i'll [ __ ] her yes i'll oh i
will give her cream pies now she allows
me too
but there's some bomb ass older folk
there's some bomb ass older folk
but when i think of 58 i think of a lady
that's like on the electric [ __ ]
wheelchair at walmart and she uses her
cane to knock over something to get and
catch into her basket
wait i just realized my mom's at the
eight now i feel weird okay i'm thinking
about it
thinking about that true yeah did your
mom look like what he described no oh
she's bomb she's a snack should we
should we pull it up yo can i get your
mom
am i hooking you up with my mom are you
my step daddy yeah
i'm down yeah this is getting sick you
call them daddy
this sounds like a spicy movie i've
never said daddy in my life i've never
called my dad daddy oh my god did she
cook
your dad a papa or hi dad via text
sometimes
so that name is reserved reserved for
joe i've never
said daddy then that's for him that's
where you honey
step daddy in the platonic way right
this
i'm just kidding last time that's not
what you said last time i know i'm gonna
say last time i was throwing myself at
him you know i you know me i'm hot and
cold yeah you're walking
honey i'm on goal oh my goodness i'm
trying to find a damn good one with my
mom everyone keep talking everyone keeps
talking she's checking your mom's
instagram
i know i need to find my mom's only fans
right now hold on
but yeah so for the support for this
article they're saying
you know this is like the typical way to
figure out your
limits on either end of the spectrum but
these aren't like finite rules that you
know if you find someone that's outside
of those limits and you you
have to say this [ __ ] like i don't know
i mean
people are wild people she is so
complete before it's not focusing oh
cover the whole camera damn is that your
sister
this way i'm sorry i'm not i'm not an
expert youtuber today
or ever i don't know i'm learning first
of all you realize that my phone
is a seven plus okay i'll help you you
got to stay humble
i'll help you cover the camera okay but
anyway
she's not like this oh i said i don't
get it hold on it's focusing there we go
we got it there we go the boys
no the contest is saying that 58 year
olds can be bomb as [ __ ]
exactly i'd never say
they couldn't wrap your tool wrap it up
honey
actually you technically don't need to
wrap it up because then like they can't
it's not the age it's the stage
no no no it's true because uh because
what they're saying here
age it's the wage it's not the age it's
the sage
oh i like that spiritual [ __ ] you know
me i'm progressive but that's that's
exactly what they're saying here in this
uh
this article is that it's not really the
age it's the stage
and that fact that um
if you if you connect with someone then
that's that's all that matters and that
sometimes
and and for this uh for these for this
mathematical way to figure out your
limits on either end
it's really just to kind of figure out a
a gauge to find someone that you would
have something
in common with so if it's too far apart
and
right you're not going to have enough to
react to each other kind of like the
whole like
yeah if she doesn't know this song she's
too young for you bro it's everything
like you can't even connect on like
things generational things right yeah
yeah there's big enough gaps like oh my
god
you're exactly like my mom right right
that's what we're gonna connect on like
if i can't
i probably couldn't date someone who
like doesn't know who the spice girls
are who or like
these are ladies that cooked with a lot
of cumin oh
spice girls it's good channel cooking
show it was a cooking show yeah
um five of them um that's cool
and but yeah i feel like or if they
don't know what like a t-mobile sidekick
is
you know yeah then they are they might
be you just don't have like
because then inside jokes and like
references they don't even get and that
can be that's the thing it's like this
is the stage right yeah
unless they're like a 22 year old that
really
oh
[Music]
you